c'est une victoire pour les apiculteurs
à partir d'aujourd'hui les
néonicotinoïdes ces insectes icipe tueur
d'abeilles et de gourdon sont
définitivement interdite en france
la fin d'un long combat pour les
producteurs de miel qui date de la fin
des années 90 océane stein qui a dit si
l'abeille disparaît l'humanité n'a plus
que cinq ans à vivre l'une des premières
alertes sur la toxicité de ces produits
c'était en 1998 à l'époque un phénomène
inquiète les apiculteurs de l'ouest de
la france leurs abeilles butinent mais
se retrouve ensuite complètement
désorienté c'est un problème de
désorganisation de leur sens de
l'orientation elles se perdent dans la
nature
et elle ne retrouve pas la ruse le
coupable selon les apiculteurs le gaucho
un insecticide vendus par l'entreprise
pharmaceutique allemand bayer depuis
1994 en 1999 le ministère de
l'agriculture interdit provisoirement
son utilisation mais uniquement pour les
semences de tournesol
en revanche il est toujours autorisé
pour le traitement du maïs pour nous ce
n'est pas complètement satisfaisant
puisque nous avions demandé le retrait
total de cette molécule est que
le problème risque quand même de
perdurer malgré ce malgré ce retrait
pour protester les producteurs de miel
réalise des actions coup de poing comme
ici en 2000 près de tours devant une des
usines de la société bayer des centaines
d'appliqués hauteur en colère viennent y
jeter leurs ruches pour manifester on va
faire un gros tas de ruches trouvait
devant celles des russes sont des
malheureuses mans il ya pour les
abeilles parce qu'on sait pas où ils
sont mais voilà ce qui nous reste
face à la pression des apiculteurs
l'utilisation du gaucho sur le maïs est
interdite en 2004 là aussi
provisoirement mais d'autres
néonicotinoïdes font leur entrée sur le
marché à l'image du cruiser en 2008
utilisé pour traiter le colza
après le régent et le gaucho le nouveau
venu s'appelle le cruiser
cette année la nouvelle manifestation
les apiculteurs
cette fois ils se déplacent jusqu'à
paris pour alerter sur la dangerosité du
produit
les abeilles vont faire comme si cette
eau le cruiser est bannie des champs de
colza en 2012 en 2018
l'union européenne supprime les usages
de trois autres néonicotinoïdes de son
côté la france va plus loin elle décide
d'en interdire 5
c'est une très bonne nouvelle ce qui
peut être inquiétant aussi c'est une
savoir par quoi ça va être remplacée
cette molécule peut être remplacé par
quelque chose qui est peut être pire que
camo et tu le départ ça maintenant seul
l'avenir nous le dira jusqu'au 1er
juillet 2020 seuls des dérogations au
cas par cas était possible elle ne
concernait que d insecticide à base
d'ascète amis pris d'1 néonicotinoïdes
utilisé notamment dans la culture de
cerises pour lutter contre les larves de
mouches
[Musique]